what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar back at it again to discuss
the latest and craziest developments in
the one piece story I did the spoilers
earlier in the week and now we got the
full review with a lot more crazy
information about Luffy's new power
luchi's Awakening their fight the crazy
secret about devil fruits and the sun
god Nika fruit Akainu and kizaru and
much more so make sure to stay tuned for
this one chill the parking with it and
smash that like button to set off the
fireworks if you enjoy seeing these one
piece reviews and updates be a smashing
King rather than passing Orochi and the
universe will reward you join the nakama
if you haven't already by subscribing
and hitting that notification Bell to
turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one piece videos and updates
so just look below the video and check
since I know some of you don't even know
you're not subscribed and now without
further Ado let's jump into It spoilers
and all this chapter is called the
desire of all things are born to this
world and it will be very relevant
indeed in this chapter specifically when
it comes to devil fruits but more on
that later so the chapter starts with
people freaking out on Egghead because
Atlas was the
and Chopper noticed cp0 as does Luffy
who's carrying Bonnie of course Chopper
calls him Rob Luchi rather than pigeon
guy as Luffy did jinbei himself is
shocked that cp0 is actually going after
vegapunk comedy ensues as Luffy asks
Luchi why he's here only for luchita's
spot it's a garment Island and it's
funny when araku realizes that yeah it
is weirder for them to be there than it
is for cp0 to be there Kaku also notices
jewelry Bonnie but says that Lucci can't
lay a hand on them since straw hat is
now a yonko and I love that they need
permission to attack our protagonist now
that's how big of a deal it is but the
history of these two guys we all know
will make it impossible for them to hold
back here and Stussy even points out
that Kaku is right since a skirmish with
ayanko can turn into an all-out War so
she says they gotta report this
immediately to the Marines Luffy leaves
Bonnie to jimbei and is then shocked to
see what happened to Atlas we can see
that Luchi is itching for a fight even
though he knows it's not a good idea a
funny moment for me is when Luffy tells
Chopper to look after Atlas only for
Chopper to agree but suggest that
Frankie may be more suited to the job
because of course the girl Luffy wants
to help is not a real human but more
like a robot Luffy can't stand what
Luchi did saying this girl gave them
meals to eat and so you know he's not
gonna let it go I love how although
Luffy wouldn't describe himself as a
hero or good guy if you mess with
someone who was nice to him he'll flip
out he has his own form of justice and I
think it's great if sakazuki is absolute
Justice and kuzan is lazy Justice then
let me know what you would call Luffy's
form of Justice in the comments and
smash that like button if you already
knew that Luffy was gonna fight Luchi at
this point and there was no going back
now speaking of sakazuki we jump to him
at Marine headquarters he's found out
that the straw hats are in Egghead and
he comments that the situation is
getting more and more complicated
sakazuki even says that the Brad should
have consulted him before forcing their
entry on Egghead and declaring a war he
knows how important this situation is if
vegapunk joins the straw hats it leaves
a crack on their enormous military
strength he asks where kisaru is and
we're told the super hype news that he's
heading for Egghead right now he says
that Luchi should wait for the Marines
to arrive and that Luchi should not
fight against straw hat at all costs
sakazuki very much the cautious one in
these recent chapters but that's
probably how a leader should be anyways
but this clears up some stuff about the
spoiler some spoilers seem to suggest
that he didn't want kizaru to go to
Egghead but in reality he appears to be
saying he wants to hold back Luchi until
kizaru and the Marines arrive so this is
definitely more hype than the initial
spoilers made me think and I'm very glad
that our straw hats will finally take on
an admiral at a point where they could
actually beat him at the very least
they'll fight as equals this time both
Luffy and Luchi are being told not to
fight and that this will become a major
incident by their respective sides but
to no avail in the control room they
also noticed luchi's Awakening and Daft
Punk says it's a rare sight not only are
they fast but as I mentioned the
spoilers it's pointed out that there are
many cases where Awakening of Zone types
robs their users of their own
personality and I think Lucci's
Awakening is rare because Luchi is still
Lucci Maybe there are some effects when
he goes into that final form but he's
still a far cry from those simple
awakened Zone jail beasts who were
nowhere near as hype as this now his
awakened form looks great I love the
black Flames that make up his hair and
even the black clouds or Flames that
surround his body just like Luffy has
but white in his awakened form perhaps
the only critique is that his form isn't
that different from his normal hybrid
form but hey it was already really cool
and not every Awakening needs to be as
dramatic as Luffy's Luchi says after
showing off his awakened leopard fruit
Straw Hat don't think you're the only
one who's gotten stronger and again you
just have Kaku in the back nervously
saying that they don't have permission
yet great stuff and I noted this in the
spoiler video but I love the world of
one piece and how time doesn't stop for
old antagonists they can still get
stronger than show up again to challenge
Luffy like this it's pretty refreshing
and great to see then Luffy's awakened
form shocks Vega punk as he speaks of
the white Warrior when he asks about the
transformation Nami simply says it's the
gobu gomu no me Vega Punk's knowledge
though leads into feel the truth that
there is no record of the me and the old
devil fruit encyclopedia at all he says
the form looks exactly like the god
mentioned in the ancient documents the
warrior of Liberation that is always
playful and puts a smile on people's
faces also known as the sun god Nika
we're further told by this genius that
Nika has been erased from history but as
long as people continue to yearn for it
its existence will never disappear and
here comes the title when he says the
desires of all things are born in this
world take for example the devil fruits
they have the potential of human
evolution that Humanity wished for
wouldn't it be nice if I was like that
or wouldn't it be great if I was like
this they have the powers of the diverse
future of humankind therefore these
abnormalities are hated by the seed the
mother of all nature their existence is
burdened with this punishment these
so-called devil fruit users are beings
living in a completely different world
that many people wish for and envisioned
that's vegapunk's Theory and he comments
on how there's no need to think about
whether there is a God or not isn't this
world so interesting he asks Oda has
always been big about this idea of
envisioning a future and the power of
that Vision to manifest in the real
world Luffy's vision of being pirate
king has brought him all this way after
all but in this chapter they take it to
an extreme where practically any desires
even literally impossible thoughts can
come about in the form of devil fruits
if our world worked like this then a lot
of us would be doing kamehameha's for
real right now but still I very much
agree in the power of desire and will to
shape the world around us it's always
been a fascinating idea to explore this
is also the whole philosophy behind
vision boards and making goals and stuff
like that by the way as vegapunk was
talking Luffy and Luchi were fighting
nothing crazy but we saw Luffy's eyes
pop out as we're used to and him stretch
his neck in humorous ways to avoid
luchi's attacks I gotta say it must be
irritating fighting a guy that just
keeps laughing during the fight as gear
5 Luffy does sento Maru AKA ax guy shows
up and asks vegapunk what to do Vega
Punk wants the seraphims to be ordered
to attack cp0 and we see them seraphims
that look like a young mihawk boa and
jimbe sentomaru is like wouldn't that
make me a Defector too but ultimately
decides to go with the man who saved him
when he had nothing to eat which was
vegapunk so tomorrow even commands the S
Bear Kuma looking one that cp0 brought
to attack those very same government
officials so tomorrow overrides their
own authority chip so they're at a huge
disadvantage right now too huge for it
to continue we already know straw hats
would beat cp0 so for there to be four
more seraphims on their side would make
no sense we have to assume that to make
this a more interesting fight the
seraphims are going to be put against
our guys we're told the rank of
authority that these seraphims follow is
one five Elders two vegapunk 3 centomaru
and four holder of the authority chip
and it looks like orders from
transponder snails don't work so they
have to be in that dangerous room I'm
guessing and the five Elders can't just
call from far away Kaku even points out
that if they win against the seraphims
it would be a loss to the world
government if they destroyed the
seraphims and he's angry that Luchi
won't think things through and again
maybe this has something to do with the
Awakening but I also feel like he wants
revenge for their fight in the past then
Luffy uses a new attack which is
hilarious it's called mole pistol and
pretty much his fist enters into the
ground like a mole digging a hole and
then comes out of the ground close to
Luchi and hits him in the gut love the
imaginativeness of it and of this whole
form finally jinbei sees his miniature
and they realize that the seraphims are
similar in looks to the former members
of the seven Warlords Jimmy thinks he
never thought they'd be able to clone
them we've been noticing the
similarities for a while on this channel
but good to actually see the warlord
seraphims pointed out as such in the
chapter Luffy after delivering a big hit
to Luchi goes over to talk to ax guy who
doesn't like being called ax guy by the
way and even says that Luffy is his
enemy still he asks Luffy if he'll help
vegapunk and Luffy agrees to take the
genius with him hashtag vagapunk for a
straw hat but also hashtag Bonnie for
straw hat anyways just as ax guy is
saying who would have thought Luffy
would become an emperor and that he
can't understand Luffy's form he's cut
short by Luchi who has recovered and
used Shogun to ruthlessly Pierce our ax
guy through the chest it was really
smart of Luchi because as he says they
just have to kill the control tower and
the seraphims will obey them so
potentially this fight already had
deadly consequences now this is actually
what Oda needed to do to make this fight
more interesting we saw how op the
seraphims are that they even made
Blackbeard Express worry so now that the
straw hats will have to potentially deal
with all of them and cp0 and kizuru
means that this has suddenly gone from a
potential blip into a huge battle that
won't be a piece of cake by any means
and I'm super down to see how Oda deals
with it and how much more the straw hats
grow in notoriety after they win and
even take vegapunk the key to a lot of
the military's might what an amazing
chapter and again Oda chose to have a
break after a hype chapter so there
won't be anything next week but this is
definitely a good Cliffhanger to keep us
excited and to hold us over until the
next chapter comes out so what you
should do right now is look down and
make sure you're subscribed so you know
when we get the spoilers or the full
review of the next chapter let me know
your thoughts on the chapter who will
take on kizuru and how long will it take
Luffy to deal with Luchi so many
questions proposed by this chapter if
you enjoyed this review and want to keep
them coming Channel parking with it and
smash that like button to set out the
fireworks if you don't see fireworks you
probably didn't do it right be a
smashing pirate king rather than a Pasco
Orochi and the universe will reward you
this chapter was actually all about that
join the nakama if you haven't already
by subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell to throw out all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and updates so like I
said before just quickly look below the
video and check since I know some of you
don't even know you're not subscribed
while you wait for the next chapter to
drop feel free to check out my huge and
growing one piece playlist which
includes videos all the yonko all
Admirals all zones and much more link to
that is in the description and on screen
now thanks again for watching and until
next time see you Space Cowboys